o avergonzar a un niño por su falta de esfuerzo en la escuela.
El 100 % de nosotros estará en el extremo receptor
de conductas de relación poco saludables
y el 100 % de nosotros haremos cosas malsanas.
Es parte de ser humano.
En su peor forma, el daño que infligimos a los seres queridos
aparece como abuso y violencia
y relaciones abusivas,
algo que una de cada tres mujeres y uno de cada cuatro hombres
experimentará en su vida.
Si eres como la mayoría, cuando escuchas esas estadísticas,
dirás, "Oh, no, no, no, eso nunca me pasaría".
Es instintivo alejarse de las palabras "abuso" y "violencia",
pensar que le suceden a alguien más en otro lugar.
Pero la verdad es que las relaciones poco sanas y el abuso nos rodean.
Simplemente las llamamos distinto e ignoramos la conexión.
El abuso nos acecha disfrazado de amor malsano.
Trabajo para una organización llamada One Love
comenzó por una familia cuya hija Yeardley fue asesinada por su exnovio.
Fue una tragedia que nadie vio venir,
pero al analizar, vieron que las señales de advertencia estaban allí
y nadie entendió lo que estaban viendo.
Llamado locura o drama o demasiada bebida,
sus acciones no se entendieron como lo que realmente eran:
signos claros de peligro.
Su familia se dio cuenta de que si alguno se hubiera educado en estos signos,
su muerte podría haberse evitado.
Hoy tenemos la misión de asegurarnos
de que otros tengan la información que Yeardley y sus amigas no tuvieron.
Tenemos tres objetivos principales:
dar a todos un idioma para hablar de un tema
que es bastante difícil e incómodo de discutir;
empoderar a toda una línea frontal, es decir, amigos, para ayudar;
y, en el proceso, mejorar toda nuestra capacidad de amar mejor.
Para hacer esto, siempre es importante comenzar iluminando
los signos poco saludables que frecuentemente omitimos,
y nuestro trabajo realmente se enfoca en crear contenido
para iniciar conversaciones con jóvenes.
Como se esperaría, la mayoría de nuestro contenido es bastante serio,
dado el tema,
Pero hoy voy a usar uno de nuestros más ligeros
que, sin embargo, todavía generan reflexión,
"Las Parejas"
para iluminar cinco marcadores de amor malsano.
El primero es la intensidad.
(Video) - No te he visto en un par de días. Te he extrañado.
- También te he extrañado. (#eso es amor)
- No te he visto en 5 minutos. Se siente como toda una vida.
¿Qué has estado haciendo sin mí durante 5 minutos enteros?
- Han pasado tres minutos. (#eso no es amor)
Katie Hood: ¿Alguien lo reconoce? No lo sé. Yo sí.
Las relaciones abusivas no comienzan abusivas.
Comienzan emocionantes y estimulantes.
Hay una intensidad de afecto y emoción, una prisa.
Se siente muy bien.
Te sientes tan afortunado, como si hubieras ganado el premio gordo.
Pero en el amor malsano, estos sentimientos cambian con el tiempo
de emocionante a abrumador y quizás un poco sofocante.
Lo sientes en tus entrañas.
Tal vez sea cuando tu nuevo novio o novia
dice "te amo" más rápido de lo que estabas listo
o comienza a aparecer en todas partes, enviando mensajes y llamando mucho.
Tal vez estén impacientes cuando demoras en responder,
a pesar de que saben que otras cosas pasaban ese día.
Es importante recordar que lo que importa no es cómo comienza una relación,
es cómo evoluciona.
Es importante en los primeros días de una nueva relación.
prestar atención a cómo te sientes.
¿Te sientes cómodo con el ritmo de la intimidad?
¿Sientes que tienes espacio para respirar?
También es muy importante comenzar a practicar usando tu voz
para hablar de tus propias necesidades.
¿Se respetan tus peticiones?
Un segundo marcador es el aislamiento.
(Video) - ¿Quieres pasar el rato?
- Mi novio y yo siempre tenemos lunes de pareja. (#eso es amor)
- ¿Quieres pasar el rato?
- Mi novio y yo siempre tenemos lunes de pareja.
- ¿Mañana? - Es nuestro martes de dormir.
- ¿El miércoles? - Día de No Amigos. (#eso no es amor)
KH: Si me preguntan, el aislamiento es de lo más olvidados
y mal entendidos signos de amor malsano.
¿Por qué?
Porque cada nueva relación comienza con este intenso deseo
de pasar tiempo juntos,
es fácil perderse cuando algo cambia.
El aislamiento se arrastra cuando tu nuevo novio o novia
comienza a alejarte de tus amigos y familiares,
tu sistema de apoyo,
y atándote más fuerte a ellos.
Podrían decir cosas como,
"¿Por qué sales con ellos? Son unos perdedores",
sobre tus mejores amigos,
o "Quieren que rompamos. Están totalmente en contra de nosotros",
sobre tu familia.
El aislamiento se trata de sembrar semillas de duda
sobre todo el mundo de tu vida anterior a la relación.
El amor sano incluye la independencia,
dos personas que aman pasan tiempo juntas, pero se mantienen conectadas
con las personas y las actividades que les importaban antes.
Mientras que al principio podrías pasar cada minuto despierto juntos,
con el tiempo mantener la independencia es clave.
Haces esto haciendo planes con amigos y apegándote a ellos,
y animando a tu pareja a hacer lo mismo.
Un tercer marcador de amor malsano son los celos extremos.
(Video) - ¿Qué te hace tan feliz?
- ¡Ella acaba de empezar a seguirme en Instagram! (#eso es amor)
- ¿Por qué estás tan nervioso?
- Ella... ella acaba de empezar a seguirme, como, en todas partes.
(#eso no es amor)
KH: A medida que el período de luna de miel se desvanece,
pueden iniciarse los celos extremos.
Tu pareja puede ser más exigente,
Necesito saber dónde estás y con quién estás todo el tiempo
o podría seguirte a todas partes, en línea y fuera de ella.
Los celos extremos también traen consigo posesividad y desconfianza,
Acusaciones frecuentes de coquetear con otras personas o engañarte,
y la negativa a escucharte cuando les dices
que no tienen nada de qué preocuparse y solo los amas.
Los celos son parte de cualquier relación humana,
pero los celos extremos son diferentes.
Hay amenaza, desesperación y enojo.
El amor no debería sentirse así.
Un cuarto marcador es el menosprecio.
(Video) - ¿Quieres pasar el rato? - Tengo que estudiar.
- Tendrás una A, igual, A de asombroso. (#eso es amor)
- ¿Quieres pasar el rato? - Tengo que estudiar.
- Tendrás una F de todos modos,
F de, F de ... estúpida. (#eso no es amor)
KH: Sí, mmm.
En el amor malsano, las palabras se usan como armas.
Conversaciones que solían ser divertidas y alegres,
se vuelven malas y embarazosas.
Tal vez tu pareja se burle de ti de una manera que duele
o tal vez cuenten historias y chistes para reírse a tus expensas.
Cuando intentas explicar que hirieron tus sentimientos,
te callan y te acusan a ti de reaccionar exageradamente.
"¿Por qué eres tan sensible? ¿Cuál es tu problema? Dame un respiro".
Estas palabras te silencian.
Parece bastante obvio, pero tu pareja debería apoyarte.
Sus palabras deberían sostenerte, no derribarte.
Deben guardar tus secretos y ser leales.
Deben hacerte sentir más confiado,
no menos.
Finalmente, un quinto marcador: la volatilidad.
(Video) - Estaría triste si rompiéramos.
- Yo también. (#eso es amor)
- Me deprimiría mucho si alguna vez rompiéramos.
Me tiraría de este escalón.
¡Lo haría! ¡No trates de detenerme!
(#eso no es amor)
KH: Rupturas y arreglos frecuentes, altos máximos y bajos mínimos:
a medida que aumenta la tensión, también lo hace la volatilidad.
Luchas desgarradoras y frustradas seguidas de arreglos emocionales,
comentarios odiosos e hirientes como
"Eres inútil, ¡ni siquiera estoy seguro de por qué estoy contigo!"
seguido rápidamente de disculpas y promesas de que nunca volverá a suceder.
En este punto, has estado tan condicionado a esta relación montaña rusa
que no te des cuenta de lo poco saludable y hasta peligrosa
en que se ha convertido tu relación.
Puede ser muy difícil de ver
cuando el amor malsano se convierte en abuso,
pero es justo decir que cuantos más de estos marcadores
tenga tu relación,
tanto más insalubre y peligrosa pudiera se sea tu relación.
Y si tu instinto es romper y salir,
que es un consejo que muchos damos a nuestros amigos
cuando están en relaciones insalubres,
ese no es siempre el mejor consejo.
El tiempo de ruptura puede ser desencadenante de violencia.
Si temes abocarte hacia el abuso o estás en el abuso,
debes consultar con expertos para obtener consejos de cómo salir de manera segura.
Pero no se trata solo de relaciones románticas
y no se trata solo de violencia.
Entender los signos del amor malsano
puede ayudarte a auditar y comprender casi todas las relaciones en tu vida.
Por primera vez, podrías entender por qué estás decepcionado por una amistad.
o por qué cada interacción con un determinado miembro de la familia
te deja desanimado y ansioso.
Incluso podrías comenzar a ver cómo tu propia intensidad y tus celos
están causando problemas con los colegas en el trabajo.
El entendimiento es el primer paso para mejorar,
y si bien no puedes hacer que cada relación no saludable sea saludable,
vas a tener que dejar algunas atrás...
puedes hacer tu parte todos los días para hacer mejor las relaciones.
Y aquí está la emocionante noticia:
en realidad, no es ciencia espacial.
Comunicación abierta, respeto mutuo,
amabilidad, paciencia...
podemos practicar estas cosas todos los días.
Y aunque la práctica definitivamente te hará mejor,
te prometo que tampoco te va a hacer perfecto.
Hago esto para vivir
y todos los días pienso y hablo de relaciones sanas,
y sigo haciendo cosas malsanas.
Justo el otro día al tratar de sacar a mis cuatro hijos a la puerta
en medio de peleas, disputas y quejas durante el desayuno,
me perdí completamente.
Con un borde intencionalmente enojado,
grité,
"¡Cállense todos solo y hagan lo que les digo!
¡Son lo peor!
¡Voy a quitarles tiempo de móvil y el postre
y cualquier otra cosa que puedan disfrutar en la vida!".
(Risas)
¿Alguien conoce esto?
(Aplausos)
Volatilidad, menosprecio.
Mi hijo mayor se dio la vuelta y me miró y dijo:
"Mamá, eso no es amor".
(Risas)
Por un minuto, realmente quería matarlo por gritarme.
Créanme.
Pero luego me recogí
y pensé, saben qué, estoy realmente orgullosa.
Estoy orgullosa de que tenga un lenguaje para hacerme parar.
Quiero que todos mis hijos entiendan lo que debería ser el mínimo
de cómo son tratados
y tener un idioma y una voz para cuando ese mínimo no se cumple
en lugar de simplemente aceptarlo.
Durante demasiado tiempo, hemos tratado las relaciones como un tema ligero,
cuando las habilidades de relación son de las cosas más importantes
y difíciles de construir en la vida.
No solo se pueden comprender signos malsanos que te ayudan
a evitar el agujero del conejo que conduce a un amor poco saludable,
sino que entender y practicar el arte de estar sano
puede mejorar casi todos los aspectos de tu vida.
Estoy completamente convencida
de que si bien el amor es un instinto y una emoción,
la habilidad de amar mejor es una habilidad que todos podemos construir.
y mejorar con el tiempo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)